hey it's andrew steven and adam before
we get started this episode was filmed
at the beginning of the year before we
started social distancing due to covet
19. yes we are currently still social
distancing but we wanted to share these
great restaurants with you even the
dining out is not the same as it usually
is right now today
we're doing rice
[Music]
potentially the
most anticipated episode of worth it
ever
uh by me okay ah by me but yours truly
rice is my favorite carb and potentially
my favorite dish and before we get
started on today's adventure special
thank you to toyota who hooked us up
with this highlander to be the new worth
mobile this season today on worth it
we're going to be trying three rice
dishes at three drastically different
price points to find out which one is
the most worth it at its price i'm
thinking about rice you know we've eaten
it so many times on this show it's an
ingredient it's a dish it can take so
many forms say rice and then i'll say a
thing rice noodle rice porridge rice
pudding rice cake wait reverse it now
sticky rice fried rice crispy rice nice
rice we're eating it rice okay so where
are we going
first we're on our way to azuma
restaurant we're gonna see owner hideki
and general manager hitoshi i'm very
excited because this restaurant was
actually referred to us by our good
friend sean miro he will be joining us
for the tasting he said they make the
most fantastic unigiri
here we are at a zuma restaurant with
our good friend sean murray so how did
it feel recommending a restaurant to
worth it it's pretty stressful because
you don't know if it's gonna be good
enough
and then also you don't want people to
show up and make it harder to get into
oh i see you're walking the door and
there's a really great energy and vibe
to it it's kind of like a cheerless
feeling can you tell us a little bit of
the background of the zuma we purchased
this restaurant 2002. it was owned by a
japanese national built by the okamoto
family in the early 50s and why has it
been important for you guys to maintain
this restaurant as an izakaya well we
liked it for one izakaya style is the
analogous to the spanish tapas lots of
little things but in addition to that we
have the regular menu items asparagus
beef is very popular here sashimi salad
and what makes a really good onigiri
lice is very important we are using
hikari rice simple but tastes really
good
it's best to start with like a plain
onigiri it's just gonna be this triangle
that's a little bit thick that's like
just the right firmness have maybe a
little bit of salt and a piece of
seaweed but otherwise it's just gonna be
this nice subtle flavor because it's
just straight up rice whoa these are
giant so this is their most standard
version no filling it's not grilled rice
salt seaweed it does have a satisfying
heft it has the weight of a perfectly
shaped snowball like i want to throw
this to somebody yeah cheers
oh the rice is naturally sweet where are
you getting sweet
are you tasting salt i'm tasting salt am
i confused wait adam please confirm for
me
maybe i'm crazy i got too much seaweed
[Laughter]
amazing how satisfying it is because
it's just it's so few elements it's
really satisfying wait eat that now so
this is um
it's like a pickled daikon mmm
love that that's sweet i think we're
going to find out in this episode that
uh my taste buds are broken so this is
the base one to give you yaki and yaki
comes from the verb yaku which means
like to grill this is how you get like
teriyaki it's how you get okonomiyaki
fun fact so what they're gonna do is
they're gonna brush it with the soy
sauce based sort of mixture then they're
gonna be grilling it charred rice is one
of my favorite flavors in the world
could have salmon salmon's really
popular one that's my personal favorite
umeboshi is like a pickled plum it
contrasts nicely with the rice flavor
stephen which one do you want i saw the
fish egg on the menu one talk about
contrast
look at that crust and then just the
smell you should be getting like this
nice toasty yeah yeah
cheers
yeah
i can never get sold wow that's almost
like a fried rice rice ball i mean i
guess it is if you'll notice in one bite
you're getting this crispy outside which
is like totally charred to perfection
and then inside is still this really
nice rice that's taken in the flavor of
the soy sauce yeah we just got to the
fish egg part
yeah very fishy i get it though this is
actually amazing it does go with the
toasted flavor of the rice very well
it's so good considering it is mostly
just rice hey not just rice like rice is
well right you're just andrew
i'm not getting in there
no i got you i know what you mean
thank you so much to sean for guiding us
through our zuma dining experience i
hope to go there again with him i know
we're about to eat two more
amazing rice dishes i have a feeling
today they're all my worth at winter you
just literally cannot go wrong with rice
stephen it's time for a little rice fact
and in fact this is going to be a pop
quiz rice fact how many
cultivated varieties of rice are there
in the world oh no
take a guess
ah
this one's hard i'm gonna say
twelve thousand five hundred and
thirty-four 12 000. the answer is 40 000
yeah you know what
ah i'll take that it's like i'm living
in pokemon red okay i've only explored
the 150 kinds of rice my rice decks is
uh it's expanding well to expand our
knowledge of distinct and delicious rice
types our next restaurant is going to
feature a very special type of rice
we're now on our way to lakshan where
we're going to see chef sang yoon and
try his heirloom black rice very nice
black rice
[Music]
lakshan was my first traditional
restaurant came from a world of very
high-end french fine dining blockchain
is sort of my rendition of how i
perceive southeast asia a place that's
full of mystery and incredible history
and this is where i interpret southeast
asia through a very modern lens my
rendition of beef and broccoli
completely change the dish and we do
some things that are very very
traditional but there's a lot of things
that we use that are tricks we use a lot
of modern cooking technique that was not
available and it's not traditional we
make something called puff beef tendon
and it will look like from afar a pork
rind but we call it the bovine cousin to
the chicharron so i think authentic but
not traditional you get a taste of
something that is so ancient and it's
still incredibly relevant the cuisine
would not be possible with only old or
only new they they have to harmonize so
tell us a little bit about this black
heirloom rice dish so the black rice
dish is also another mysterious
ingredient people used to call it
forbidden rice and i was like well why
is it forbidden the story is that it was
only once available to royalty and if
you were just a normal person you
weren't allowed to have it although it
is not technically forbidden it isn't
incredibly widely available even in
china so i wanted to make a rice dish
that was about the rice itself there's a
small amount of cantonese sweet sausage
called lemshang the rice is the star of
the show and not simply a side i think
that's a completely different
perspective on rice thing about black
rice is it's very forgiving in that it
can take on a lot of the heat from the
wok black rice actually just gets
smokier you get almost that light scorch
that waft of smoke i've actually never
seen black rice cooked this way
[Music]
i'm willing to bet this is going to be a
completely new experience
too steven
[Music]
mmm whoa
yeah it's a nice chewy grease
chewy wow i thought i was an expert in
rice i don't know
you've been stumped by rice how do you
describe that texture it's springy
bouncy like seedy almost
i want to buy this rice i'm going to
find out where they get this they have a
guy i want that guy get me that guy you
want to have some egg with it now now
this is what i like to see
now that is the familiar taste i know
and love but then earthy nutty
herbaceous other rice flavor i notice
every single grain of rice when i eat it
each grain holds up by itself all of the
other stuff in this dish stay very
separate until you get a bite from them
yeah you're eating it oh this is good
whoa
that's
also good when i saw this bowl of rice
my like mind it gets stuck it's like
you're looking at a image in negative
like why is the white bar black actually
like i shouldn't be eating it i guess
that's why it's called the forbidden
rice
gosh what a flavorful
grain of rice i think it has made me
reconsider my own personal rice options
at home so used to just getting the one
i grew up on
but i think it's time to start buying
other bags of rice so we've had two
savory rice dishes our last rice dish is
actually going to be a dessert but
before we get there it's time for one
more rice fact
while the great wall of china was being
built in the 15th and 16th centuries
workers used a porch made of calcium
carbonate and rice as a mortar to hold
the stones together
steven lim loves a good chemical
engineering rice fact look at that
the foundation to my diet and the
foundation to a mortar i wonder if
people
snuck bites of it and inadvertently
cemented their stomach shut
so we're on our way to our last rice
dish we're going to auburn where we're
going to speak with chef eric and we're
actually going to be eating at the
restaurant's bar the dish is white
chocolate risotto which is the creation
of pastry chef diane also has white
truffle on it as somebody who has eaten
rice his entire life this will be
probably the craziest rice dish i will
ever eat
auburn is a modern product driven
restaurant that looks to deformalize
fine dining make it approachable i mean
the first thing i noticed was what
you're wearing is this your daily work
where is this what you're wearing during
service it is it is i'll throw in a
collar tonight
so deformalizing fine dining what does
that mean at auburn to me it means
removing the rules typically you go into
a fine dining you're told how many
horses you need to take everyone takes
the same thing so you wanted to
deformalize fine dining and then if
that's too formal you still have the bar
exactly yeah we want to make it
energetic for everyone right so where
the dining room is tasty menu format the
bar is completely out of cart we use the
same products just in a different way so
sea bream is a beautiful product this is
from japan it's very well treated so
it's brought on the boat line caught so
the flesh is pristine we really want to
highlight the filet in the dining room
and then in the bar obviously the collar
is typically an off cut more fatty so
our bar gives us the ability to offer
that to guests we're going to be having
this risotto which is a dessert it is a
dessert it's between a dessert and
something savory which makes it very
unique and super delicious
the white chocolate risotto yes with
white truffle
i guess i'm just wondering how you came
up with this dish we were getting in
these beautiful hazelnuts like the best
hazelnuts that i've ever tasted and then
we were getting in our orders of white
truffles we use a very good risotto rice
called aquarello after they harvest it
they age it for one to three years it
enhances the flavor but also it makes it
so the rice can absorb as much liquid as
possible but still maintaining like the
structure of the rice where you cook it
and it's not mushy and you eat it and
you still feel the individual grains of
rice in your mouth while you're chewing
it
so we're here at the bar of this
beautiful restaurant that's behind this
wall
i like that it's like an unplanned fine
dining meal since it's a dessert though
we should build up to the experience
right so first we're getting the crispy
pig ear i grew up in north carolina we
have a lot of crispy pork rinds we
braise pig's ears for about 12 hours we
slice them we dehydrate them and then we
fry them and what we get is like a very
puffed chicharron we top it with sea
salt vinegar powder and fresh black
pepper
flying in wow chips at a bar
i like it strangest texture it reminds
me of like a packet of ramen noodles
before you boil it yes
cheers okay
[Music]
wow
wow i could just eat that forever the
vinegar kind of like tastes sweet
against all of the other
stuff happening that's crazy whoa
and this is kind of like a salt and
vinegar chip but on
kind of like a porky
puff
it's scary because uh
we got some shrapnel flying off the
mouth there
the sea beam color is very unique
smaller delicious we cure it in a
mixture of salt sugar and citrus fern
citrus and fish go really well together
in california here we have very unique
citrus called finger lime it looks like
little caviar pearls so we come up with
a little bit of spice a lot of acidity a
little bit of funk it's not dressed it's
very simply put on a plate
cheers
[Music]
oh god oh when when fish is good it is
the best meat oh my gosh
[Music]
oh
yeah oh man
okay
that's heaven i could eat
30 of these
why would you want to order a dessert
dish of all things that has white
truffle well i think if you're really
interested in food and you want to try
something that you haven't tried before
it would naturally speak to you i think
it's just something you're gonna have to
try and you guys should just let me know
okay at first i thought huh smells like
uh kind of a nutty dessert and now i'm
back into huh it smells like i'm about
to eat pasta
i i feel like the world just you know
when like there's a portal we're at the
portal about to step into another realm
yeah
all right stephen
let's step into that realm
cheers stephen
to the portal we
go oh
[Music]
i feel like my muscles when i eat this
are just expanding and i want to stretch
and i don't know
what's causing that
feeling this is really good it's a lot
sweeter than i thought it was going to
be i thought the truffle was going to
overpower all the sweetness that
happened the rice pudding behind i'm
getting yeah it is like a very nice rice
pudding it's very comforting yeah the
truffle is not that weird in here i
think it shares a nightiness with the
hazelnut which shares a butteriness with
the white chocolate which goes with the
vanilla broth that the risotto was
cooked in it's actually not very crazy
at all that's one of the most
intelligent things you ever did on this
show well done i can't get over the idea
that i'm just eating a truffled rice
krispie treat porridge
rice krispie treat with truffle it's so
good there's no moment of like
i'm confused by what i'm eating but
maybe it makes sense it's just like
immediately delicious i am
completely satisfied with that rice
journey it was a very satisfying day of
eating rice what was your favorite thing
of the episode that wasn't right my
favorite part of the episode where we
talk about not the food the design of
auburn it reminds me of some danish
alternate life that i'll never get to
live how about you my answer is tea
salad at lakshan mmm salad salad was
maybe the best thing at luxon whoa bold
words yeah all right andrew which one
was your worth it winner my worth at
winner is gonna go to
luxon whoa that black heirloom rice is
so unique it tastes so delicious and
different you know what's crazy is that
i'm about to choose uh something and
that leaves out the other one
yeah and i can't believe that other one
is not either of our worthy winners
because my worth it winner goes to azuma
the rice ball it is the simplest version
of this dish that could have been done
my winner does not go to the grilled
onigiri oh really it actually goes to
the plain
rice ball the simplicity of it cannot be
beaten
but i can't believe auburn is neither
because that was
spectacular auburn is really next level
adam what was your worth of winner
adam says auburn man auburn was so good
next we're going on a little road trip
out of la road trip
[Music]
you